[Music]
tymberlee suit court half-eaten already
okay so today food court would like to
honor a true food Patriot Don Gorske he
was on track to eat an earth-shattering
thirty thousand McDonald's Big Macs by
May so he started eating two Big Macs
every day since May 17th 1972 whoo yeah
I think he's gonna have me beat
that's about 14 Big Macs a week and it
is an honor to have a Big Mac here no
onions you know how I like it
Thank You Shauna rule why is he doing
this is this for a charity record what
that is we don't we just assume that's
normal
okay okay fine I just wanted just a
great company you know I'm just saying
it's just kind of strange anyway